this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
so good afternoon welcome to EE 292 H
engineering and climate change we have a
wonderful guest lecturer today Rex
northern but we have a few
administrative things to go over first
for a couple minutes and a little bit of
review because we had a number of people
just joined the class within the last
week so first off please I I got so
convinced this is a great book for you
folks to read that I bought a few copies
as group property of the class that's
how you do it except take take the
signup sheet put your name and the
number on it and you'll be good so you
could pass the signup sheet around here
you have just elected yourself the new
distributor that's what heads up
behavior will get you oh and let's see
so yes beautiful which is a less
polluting option so if you've got the
money go ahead and do that otherwise you
can borrow these which I think will just
become class property over the years so
the purpose of this course is we went
over last week is really to provide you
with a start on the tools and
information that you need so you can
make a difference basically in an
intelligent difference on the challenges
brought by climate change and as we said
I won't review too many slides from last
week but again for the newcomers this
this matters science is critically
important it's what's telling us that we
have a problem right and policy is
critically important without it change
is really difficult for businesses and
you know regular folks to make but this
classes focus is engineering and this
book that's making the rounds is an
interesting example of how to get
empowered to make a difference with that
and Rex northern today will be a very
interesting data point for us to figure
out how on earth you fund that once
you've had that lightning bolt idea
so here we are I spoke last week if
you're new and haven't listened to the
lecture please do their online through
SCPD and your homework is to write a
summary every week of what the class was
so no grades but you you cannot pass the
course if you are not writing the
summaries Rex will speak this week
Kimberly we fling is speaking next week
she will help us so here we are with how
to fund these these ideas and next week
is how to generate ideas to basically
impossible problems so that'll be pretty
interesting the other way of looking at
this lineup is you know the earth at the
middle with all these ideas and problems
of money etc yes is that one guess yeah
SGS I 2007 is a beautiful collection
yeah you might have been the one who
sent me that email if do we have to read
it all this week so I'll get to that in
a second I changed things based on your
feedback thanks what I basically put up
was a library of things you might be
interested in reading over the court I
hope you didn't have too stressful week
trying to tear through Paul that I
started reading and I stopped after 15
minutes um here's next week's but I
applaud your enthusiasm here's next
week's guest lecture Kimberly we fling
she you will enjoy her many students in
the past couple quarters that I've
taught this have really thought she was
one of the highlights because she will
help you think through all kinds of
challenges that you've got even beyond
this class logistics send me an email
please la field at stanford.edu if you
need anything if you are not registered
in the class but want to hear some class
announcements and want to join a mailing
list I'm not going to be passing around
an attendance sheet anymore because I
can tell by your summaries whether
you're here and actively engage so
please just send me an email if you want
to add yourself to to the list
so the class lecture somebody that's my
attendance we're starting to lecture
promptly at 1255 that's when the one
person with a cross-country sprint could
get here by the course works web page
some great readings are available they
are not all mandatory and so what I have
on there is this glorious resource the
SGS I Summer Institute readings from
2007 are a wonderful resource of some
basic climate change papers and they are
from the SGS I class was taught by Terry
root and Steve Schneider the late Steve
Schneider that's how I got to meet them
and it was a fantastic course meant to
within one week so you'll see monday
readings tuesday readings within one
week to bring people up to speed enough
in this area to start you know being
able to have an intelligent discourse
about it but what i have done is grayed
out most of the readings so supposedly
you guys can't see them on course works
and i'll only be ungraded on the side so
I've ungraded the Monday readings now
which is a lot of readings so that you
can go through that if you want then
I'll this week on gray the Tuesday
readings read them on the side they are
not mandatory but they are terrific and
and let's see I've been having you mail
your summaries to me that turns out to
be a lot to manage we've got 33 students
registered for the class now so I have
discovered course works will help me
with that and some of you were asking
why isn't this on course work so I will
figure out how to get you to submit your
summaries to a course work site at class
work site of course works I think I got
it wrong here and I can look at them
they're so I'll get that set up as soon
as possible because I would love you to
have your some reason by the day after
the lecture if possible it's easier for
you to remember and lock it in your
brain I'll try and get that set up this
afternoon videos of the class are
available if you want to review them but
it's better to attend live so you can
ask questions if you are here SCPD
students it's better to do everything
you can
if even from remotely it's set up so you
can succeed in that to office hours we
could meet before class over lunch
upstairs but I think I can tell from the
way today when I would need an email if
you're intending to do that so I know I
better be there by noon I got there by
about twelve twenty so and your homework
each week please summarize the lecture
I'm suggesting by Wednesday if you're
attending class on Tuesday it's only one
thoughtful paragraph some of you by the
way had the most impressive summaries
they were just gorgeous they were wow
they really really got it that was that
was very nice those tended to be the
longer paragraphs although some of them
were were kind of short with some really
insightful things so thank you by Sunday
night you know do some reading for the
next lecture I will suggest ones or find
your own and let us know what was even
more relevant and email me at least one
burning question for lecture to consider
again sample test case I didn't get a
chance to actually tabulate the rest of
them came in and get them direct still
yesterday who of course was busy because
he's got a lot to do and he got to look
at them a little before class if you
want the lectures just to be able to
consider them even more deeply you might
mail them even earlier so I don't get
them on for next week the reading but
they were great but to see what you guys
are worrying about and thinking about it
promises well for our discussion for
next week there's the d.school bootcamp
boot leg that's on the course work site
and that is a beautiful little PDF from
Stanford's design school that is meant
to take you through some of this design
process thinking and with Kimberly here
next week to give you some more ideas of
how to really create solutions that
answer the real problem that'll be a
good one also check out Kimberly site we
fling calm and those optional on the
side these SGS I Stanford Graduate
Summer Institute 2007 readings are
unblocked out you can take a look at
them at least once in the quarter I'd
love each of you to suggest some reading
meeting or lecture or tell us a research
groups thing that we need to be aware of
that would be great
you could even go and do a quick
research turn project or a quick cord up
on what the G step meeting or the
cleantech open was and you've got it
yeah you've got it on and that's
unfortunate and and also check out this
website Kimberly's we fling.com website
it will give you a leg up on what the
kind of thing she can answer our and
then there's all kinds of opportunities
you are in a wealth of opportunity some
of you as we know from last week our
real experts in this area already so you
should probably tell us the ones I know
about our Sally Benson's professor Sally
Benson's energy seminars weekly they had
the head of arpa-e yesterday I couldn't
make it but I think they actually
videotaped these and you can get them
online so that would be very nice the g
sep annual meeting today meeting is next
week fantastic two days really get you
up to speed in the area quite well the
energy club get on their meeting notices
if you aren't already and nearby the MIT
Club of Northern California has lots of
meetings one that's coming up October
25th is this smart grid one which is a
subject I feel bad that we haven't
included this quarter but you could see
it there the cleantech open Rex will be
able to tell us a lot about and that's
in november eighth and ninth is the
Academy Awards of cleantech coming up
are good and the agu annual meeting I'm
quite fond of because it goes in with my
own environmental nonprofit thing the
American Geophysical unions annual
meeting so a lot of people there who
scientists who worry about ice and
oceans and that that's a great one up in
San Francisco I saw two hands you first
oh and also this thursday i'm 3 30 years
Thank You woods Institute seminars ok i
will add that to our own suggestion ok
and that atmosphere and energy group has
seminars on
stays at 12 15 well 13 12 15 oh that's
right now huh seminars if you're ever
not going to this class Joyce is just
enough for that to you I suppose I don't
but you but if you do you got to watch
the video of this class extra specially
attentively and write me a great summary
great and some of our insights just one
page of our insights from last week from
this gorgeous book which hopefully lots
of you have borrowed now so this again
is on the side this isn't mandatory but
I think it's a great one our choices for
response to climate change or mitigation
adaptation and suffering and that it's a
wonderful a wonderful entrepreneurial
opportunity if you want to look at it as
an optimist and one more empowering book
again not mandatory but just fun Tina
Seelig what I wish I knew when I was 20
any of you read this boy is that a great
book I ordered one copy that I could
loan but you got to give it back what so
you can okay so you guys are willing to
buy kindle materials that's just a
beautifully empowering book so the
question to keep in mind for yourselves
now besides all the ones you're going to
ask Rex in a couple minutes what do you
need to learn here what are you going to
try and with that here is the cleantech
open subject let's say a little bit
about Rex what are you introducing
yourself or shall I what I shall you go
for listening he is the executive he
knows more about himself than I do Rex
is amazing the executive director of the
cleantech open under his leadership it
has gone from a regional competition to
a national competition to an
international competition it has the
potential to have when it already has
made a huge difference in the world in
finding fun during and fuss finding
funding and fostering the most promising
clean tech
technologies and teaching crazed
engineers how to present their ideas in
a way that investors looking for an
opportunity can relate to and say oh I
mean I think that's just an amazing
public service right there and Rex is an
entrepreneur on his own I mean in his
history so he knows all the issues that
people trying to start something go go
through let's see on the global clean
tech open that's the international one
and an MA from the University of Oxford
so a very classy accent as well so again
with that Rex is speaking today and we
went through that we're set except we
have to get ourselves on to Rex's very
warm this room oh um no but you know
what I will go see if I can find you
something how's that okay great oh I
won't just turn it alrighty Thank You
Lizzie alrighty so um we just redress
myself here so how many of you consider
yourselves crazed engineers is that the
right oh and let me ask you a different
question how many of you had had come
across the cleantech open in some way
shape or form before you heard about
this class view of you how many of you
have a terrific lightning bolt idea to
use Leslie's language does this really
badly have a nicer you know a really
outstanding idea you'd like to see
funded
it's all going to theoretical hello come
on okay and well you've had am I the
first speaker in this series okay so I'm
going to give you a little bit of a of
an overview use this process of what the
space is about but I want to kind of set
the scene for a second or two and make
sure you're clear on what this all means
and why I'm here and what the cleantech
open is and how this all kind of fits
together in terms of a stamp for class
on engineering climate change I'm going
to give you a very specific perspective
so what I mean by that is that i'm going
to talk from the perspective of somebody
who does have a lightning bolt idea and
that's usually how it starts
entrepreneurs in the clean tech space
are usually pretty passionate and that's
both good and bad and I hope I'll have
time to cover the good and the bad of it
but it's that there's there's a lot to
explain about the way that this market
works and the way that an entrepreneur
from the ground up from a grassroots
perspective actually distracted by
myself up on that screen now to put my
cell phone you know some blinkers on can
can make a real difference and so as a
kind of introductory stage in this whole
thing let me talk about what clean tech
is and what it all means and why clean
tech is important and how the
entrepreneur fits into the whole thing
and I've got your questions and I did
have a chance to look at them quite
quickly so let's hope i can find enough
time to make sure we answer all those
questions at least most of them starting
point because many of you ask this what
is clean tech it's a bit different from
the old language behind green tech clean
tech is doing well while doing good and
that's a summary of what the clean tech
group here uses his language Thank You
Leslie very much to explain what clean
takes all about it's this kind of
combination of superior performance at
lower costs which sounds like the kinds
of things that engineers do generically
am i right it's not so much a clean tech
thing but the second thing really is
reducing or eliminating neg
native ecological impact the same time
as in pretty improving the productive
and responsible use of natural resources
otherwise known as sustainability and
it's that combination of those three
things that makes up this clean tech
space it's a space where you have to
devise better products that are going to
make an environmental difference so
impact is part of it an impact is a key
part of this whole thing so the kinds of
companies that approach the cleantech
open have to be companies that are going
to make an impact of some kind
environmentally and they need to do it
in a sustainable way we categorize clean
technologies into these six different
areas renewable energy which you all
know about solar and wind and the like
that's that's about energy generation
energy efficiency is about use of energy
more efficiently smart power is
typically about the distribution of
energy usually talks about this thing
called the smart grid meters in your
home meters in your business and then
the means by which the energy gets to
the home and the commercial property
transportation air water and waste and
green building green building is about
both the construction and the
utilization of building facilities so
better ways of building buildings and
better ways of using buildings air water
and waste very obviously we're looking
for technologies which will help us to
mitigate the pollution of water and of
the air and the the better use of solid
wastes typically usually those wastes I
get burned in some way shape or form
obviously in meeting some carbon that's
having the process but we we're talking
about the utilization of waste in a
better fashion transportation is
normally about electric vehicles more
than anything else nowadays if I'm sure
you know about the whole fuel cell
progress fuel cells really are not
taking off in a big way yet electric
vehicles are starting to come into their
own and particularly battery
technologies the kinds of technologies
that we will use to in fact the big
issue there of course is driving down
the cost per mile driven batteries are
very very efficient in terms of
talk they're very very efficient for
driving motors an engine a electric
engine is about seventy to eighty
percent efficient versus about fifteen
percent for a gasoline engine or twenty
percent for a diesel engine but the
challenge we have is that the batteries
are massively expensive now so you need
to have a lot of money to buy yourself a
Tesla Model S or something equivalent to
have the batteries to give you something
a 300-mile range so that's that's the
big issue we're trying to address now
I'm going to talk about the investment
environment i'm going to let macro
issues and micro issues i'm going to
talk about some of the things that are
going on right now so here are some of
the questions that we need to address
and rather than can appear around then
the pull out a piece of paper so I can
going to read off from here and some of
the big challenges in this space well
the first of them is that we haven't
reached the stage for most of the world
in most of these technologies well we
have grid parity what I mean by that
what I mean is that it's still cheaper
in most instances to buy your
electricity from an alternative source
from a fossil fuel source than it is to
buy from a renewable source we're
getting there and we'll talk about some
of the things that are happening there
is a lot of dysfunction right now in
Congress particularly in the US the
whole clean tech space and renewable
energy space has become something of a
political football I'm sorry to say you
may have noticed it in fact the
politicians won't even use the phrase
phrases like climate change and global
warming right now as a result of some of
the things that have been happening
there so we have an environment which is
not conducive to this this kind of
technological development at China many
people think the Chinese eating our
lunch China just announced in September
a 600 billion dollar investment in the
smart grid and it's the kind of thing
that the u.s. typically doesn't do we
don't have an industrial policy where
the government mandates was going to
happen in the US at a national level the
Chinese most certainly do and the
proportion of electric vehicles and even
electric boats is growing very rapidly
if you drive around China and I've only
done it a little bit mice
you will see solar thermal on people's
roofs quite commonly solar thermal
meaning the heating of water by the Sun
so China and Europe have an environment
which are quite a lot more conducive to
this sort of thing particularly than we
have in the u.s. an entrepreneurial
hubris well last year the big news was a
company called cylindrica said of them
when I asked this question a year ago
almost nobody had interestingly and it
only just happened but Solyndra has
really gone into the public psyche 535
million dollars worth of taxpayer money
sunk and in the scale of things it's not
really a lot of money and it's not
really a big deal we waste unfortunately
at government level far more money than
that on far more far less worthwhile
project but nevertheless it's been
picked up and part of this football
we've been talking about unfortunately
so we've had we've had opportunities
here which have turned into threats and
disasters for the space and some VCS are
putting out the pulling out of the space
altogether and some of you and your
questions have raised this question some
VCS are seeing this space as being too
capital intensive and too slow to invest
in at the same time there are some big
opportunities and we are talking by the
way at the macro level I promised you
that I would start off by talking about
some of the big macro issues these are
the issues that you typically can't
affect all the kinds of things you
haven't affected yet okay maybe some of
you will be having an impact on some of
these things over time economic mandates
well there are a series of potential
mandates that could be delivered at a
policy level again some of you asked
questions about this plenty of good
examples of little things that happen
the EPA is there delivering mandates and
regulations for which which regulate
water pollution levels and so on so
forth lots of those are happening and
plenty of technologies get into the
market by virtue of those things so
opportunities we need to develop us
conditions
for startups and we need to find more
opportunities for those kind of mandates
in other words four ways of making these
kinds of things happen and mandating
that they happen environmental mandates
are very very important to us and as the
economy as the risk as the recession
that we've seen in the US continues only
to be resolved very slowly as the as
some countries in Europe fall into
recession a second time but that double
dip so the economic issues and the
environmental issues get tied up so
there are some big reasons that I'm
going to come onto in a second why the
environment in the economy are going to
be driven by clean tech solutions market
dynamics technologies across the chasm
who has read Jeffrey mores book crossing
the chasm anyone will you guys and
entrepreneurs yet but I hope you will
recrossing the chasm we're talking about
technologies that have reached the stage
of being in Main Street Geoffrey Moore
is one of these seminal writers on the
whole space and he talks about early
adopters versus what happens when a
technology really starts to hit the top
end of the bell curve and technologies
that grow grow through something called
the chasm basically it means that as a
technology starts to grow typically we
have a little bit of a problem between
the early adopter the kind of crazy guy
that the first people that bought plasma
TV sets the first people who have bought
electric vehicles and so forth how do
you get from those early guys to the to
the main street to to Main Street you
out buying these things so we'll talk a
bit about that and it's also worth
pointing out that some VCS are more
bullish than ever anyone here ahead of
Vinod Khosla and khosla ventures is
doing very well thank you very much as
are some of the other VCS in the clean
tech space and they will bang the drum
and basically say that the only reason
that VCS haven't made money in cleantech
is they don't know what they're doing
you have to make the right kind of
investment these are different sort of
specs so this is the kind of overview of
the macro level issues we're talking
about and we're still on macro we're
talking about the environment in which
we operate and this
series of charts here really just goes
to show that in spite of what we think
overall the investment going into clean
tech continues and it continues to grow
so if you look at cleantech funding
trends and clean tech vs overall a
venture capital you will see that it's
growing it about the same pace overall
as the rest of the market in fact clean
tech since the early 2000s has grown
dramatically more quickly than the rest
of the VC space about thirty percent of
all venture capital goes into the clean
tech space now which from from a
starting point of almost nothing so we
have over this past 12 years or so
seeing a dramatic increase in the total
amount of venture capital going in and
it's not falling off why well because
clean tech is the opportunity is the
space that's going to grow more quickly
than anything else in the long term all
markets are exponential and what I mean
by that is they grow on an exponential
curve like this and we are on that
rather frustrating slow growth of the
exponential curve now things will start
to change as some of these technologies
come into their own as batteries hit the
stage where they can be put into
vehicles and they can be driven for the
same kind of cost per mile in fact the
cost per mile is much lower but the same
kind of acquisition cost as a
traditional vehicle then things will
really dramatically change one of the
companies that actually applied for the
clean tech opened it didn't make it as a
company called Proterra and I went to
see protaras production plant a couple
of weeks ago in South Carolina and it's
phenomenal I mean they're building
electric buses and these electric buses
today cost about a million dollars each
to buy and they're competing with diesel
buses which typically cost about a
quarter of that so it's quite a big
decision to buy an electric bus for four
times the price of its traditional
counterpart why would you do it well in
part because there are government
subsidies available to you for doing it
but the real reason is to deal with
cost per mile the cost per mile of a
traditional diesel bus is about 20 times
that of an electric bus and traditional
and all buses on average operate about
45,000 miles per year within 18 months
this company reckons that they will have
an electric bus for about the same
acquisition cost as a diesel bus so if
you can buy these things for about the
same price they should expect to see an
exponential growth in their sales right
now we're on that slow part of the curb
it's very frustrating to be on the slow
part of any curve but when things start
to change these technologies become much
less expensive than the traditional
counterparts it's a combination of
things and battery technology using
increasing an efficiency by about eight
percent a year which is a slow exponent
but still it's an exponential curve
ultimately and it's but in their
particular cases to do with the fact
that they have driven costs out of the
manufacturing process and they continue
to drive them they're using a carbon
fiber moulding to build the buses
themselves and that's expensive to
develop but it becomes cheaper when you
produce it a volume a lot of these
things that they do with scale
fundamentally it's very expensive to
produce one gallon of a biofuel but it's
much much much much much cheaper to
produce a million gallons and probably
not for another five or six years where
we hit the stage where we're producing
millions of gallons of these biofuels
that some of you may have heard about
and only when that happens what we start
to see that kind of thing okay it means
that in the biofuels space just to give
that particular example and what's
happening well biofuels companies are
not competing with gasoline they can't
because gasoline is a commodity and
there are massive refineries producing
it and the drilling and exploration
process is well established so biofuels
companies are going into the specialist
space of specialist chemicals specialist
chemicals instead of costing maybe a
or two or three or four per gallon might
cost twenty or thirty dollars per gallon
so biofuels companies are starting their
that's how they're getting their stout
on the exponential curve but they will
eventually bring drive these costs down
through scale to hit the tip that the
bigger commodity markets all right so
venture capital and the overall capital
going to into clean tech over all these
not slowing down so from a macro
perspective there's plenty of
opportunity there this is that this is a
chart which I don't often show it just
shows you the applications that we get
actually these are the participating
companies but their reflection of the
applicants that participating the
cleantech open every year and I might as
well do 30 seconds on clean tech up
unless he's explained it very well we
are the world's largest accelerator for
clean tech startups so we only work with
very very little companies and we look
for ways of helping accelerate them
through the early stages of building a
company why well because most companies
unfortunately when they start when
they're very very young will fit most
young companies do not make it pass
about five years and that wouldn't
matter terribly much except for some of
these companies could say the pact so
here we are crazy nonprofit e-type
people that we are looking for ways to
give them the entrepreneurial skills to
get through those very early stages in
the valley of death and the chasm that I
mentioned before and deliver successful
clean tech companies from a very
promising cleantech idea you will see
from this unfortunately colors aren't
very easy to see some of them are a
little bit confusing you'll see here
that we get most of the entries here in
the energy space we got a lot in
renewable energy and an even bigger
number in smart power and if I move on
you will see that when it comes to
funding the kinds of companies that get
the funding interestingly enough and
this is at all stages of the renewable
energy companies can you see that okay
so what's really interesting to us is
that
renewable energy new forms of producing
energy tend to get more of the capital
that could mean venture capital or
strategic capital will differentiate
between those two things in a second or
two than anything else this is not
something this is information which we
only give out very occasionally but it
gives you the information for the 581
companies in the US it completed our
process that's far and gives you a feel
for where things are going again I hope
this helps answer some of your questions
about what the trends are certainly what
we're seeing in terms of early-stage
companies should all these early stage
companies be going into renewable energy
well we'll discuss that later on okay
another macro thing you've all probably
heard of United Nations this is a screen
from Rio plus 20 the Rio plus 20 earth
summit was on earlier this year and I
went along in fact this is me on a panel
you can see the panelist next to me is
actually falling asleep while I'm
talking and real plus 20 was fascinating
from my perspective it was fascinating
because there were some macro things
going on there are people out there who
are getting stressed about the fact that
in their view fossil fuel companies are
getting more subsidies than green
alternatives are so that so one of the
things here that they did was they they
got a trillion dollar bill which is
their calculation of how much money is
going to subsidize oil exploration they
got a trillion dollar bill on Copacabana
beach in Rio and they said let's turn
this bill green in other words let's get
a trillion dollars for alternative
sources of energy it was fascinating and
also she that's not the fascinating was
fascinating also because there's a big
drive there to to do a series of things
which are very relevant to the
entrepreneur in real plus 20 unlike the
original real earth summit the reason
that real president he was called plus
20 is because was 20 years on from the
first earth summit in 1992 and in 1992
the governments of the world got to
other and they built a big framework of
a big framework agreement which
basically said that we recognized global
warming is coming and the world needs to
work together and the Kyoto Protocol
came out of that original framework
agreement in real plus 20 none of that
happened in fact Obama didn't go most of
the the big heads of state didn't turn
up in person European heads were not
there this time around why because there
aren't any votes right now apparently in
this whole area but what did happen was
that there are a whole series of
initiatives that were launched one of
them is called sustainable energy for
all and sustainable energy for all is
about providing energy for the for the
about half the world's population that
don't have adequate access to energy and
another piece of it was about increasing
energy efficiency if we if we were to
just deploy existing energy efficiency
technologies we could double take from
about fourteen percent today fourteen
percent of these of these of products in
the market have some kind of energy
efficiency solution in them we could
double that by 2030 we could help those
people who have no access to energy have
access and and where the solution is
going to come from well the the message
from the UN was that it's not going to
come from governments governments are
not going to deliver these kinds of
solutions anymore so where were they
looking they were looking at the
entrepreneur there were a large number
of presentations from entrepreneurs the
the call was to entrepreneurs to find
solutions here there is a therefore a
huge macro opportunity for solutions in
this space and entrepreneurs and
engineers who are looking to find
solutions are a key part of that mix
jobs part of the economic mandate that I
mentioned
jobs this actually shows that the GDP of
the US has been growing fairly
consistently actually since the great
big recession which are those blue bars
that are below the line we have this the
Great Recession took place since then
we've had fairly consistent growth in
GDP but that can put the growth with
those yellow bars or yellow columns has
not been consistent by any means it's
been erratic and all over the place the
same time here in Silicon Valley things
are a lot better in fact we're almost
back to where we started we're at back
to what something like 90s or says
ninety-seven percent of the
pre-recession peak here in Silicon
Valley jobs are a very very big deal and
in the clean tech space there is a very
big jobs mandate anyone got any idea
what we use as the fuel source and how
much it costs when you build a wind farm
what's the fuel source well do we need
diesel for example in a wind farm we
don't actually we use wind in a wind
farm right well to build them thank you
very much thank you all right so we
don't completely we don't completely
kill the ground for fossil fuels as part
as well it depends of course we and we
might use renewable energy as part of
the production process but the deal is
that the fuel source in in a renewable
plant in a in a utility-scale plant is
typically free it's typically free
barring the building peace thank you
very much reservation and the
installation yes and the driving the
workers to the installation so all
important things unless they drive up
and they will so so it's typically free
but typically you also have
significantly more jobs funnily enough
people are looking for ways to take
these jobs out of the puzzle
because we will drive costs down by so
doing but it's something like 10 times
more jobs to maintain a solar plant than
it is to maintain a traditional fossil
fuel plant and about two to three times
more for a wind plant another macro
issue another area that really affects
you all being in the u.s. is a really
good idea as an entrepreneur and it's AB
it's a pretty obvious is something put
together by Uggla got'em and all those
dots represent different countries and
essentially what it says here is that
the economic fundamentals and the
environment in which you operate are
correlated surprise surprise so where we
have the kind of environment where we
have venture capital available where we
have rule of law where people can't
steal your ideas your intellectual
property can be properly protected and
so forth so you will tend to increase
your propensity to succeed so in other
words being in the u.s. at a macro level
is a really good idea entrepreneurship
and clean tech therefore I posit are a
good place to be there are lots of
reasons why this is going to be an
exciting space to be in and back to the
economic mandate for a second this is
actually right back at the beginning of
the recession really when the Wall
Street Journal Tom Hayes and Michael
Malone said the only way the American
economy is going to regain its lost
health and vitality is to lead the world
into the future entrepreneurs are the
only people who can get us there um I'm
going to convince this piece of the
puzzle just by talking about what might
interest you this is showing you what's
happened within our world within the
clean tech open world so we're kind of
moving towards the micro now and explain
to you that these companies have raised
now slightly north of seven hundred
million dollars these figures are always
out of date so 581 US companies have
raised slightly north of seven hundred
million dollars but what's very
interesting from from your perspective
is that the blue piece there is
California and the clean tech opens map
which I don't have
to show you a clinic opened map covers
most of the Union most states of the
union there is a huge amount happening
in California this is a good place to be
as an entrepreneur the same kind of
picture applies to patents issued and
see here that two-thirds of all the
patents issued two companies in the
cleantech opens history have been in
California now it's it's not that
surprising we actually get more
applications from California companies
and we do from the rest of the country
but no longer more than the rest of the
country put together so now we get
slightly under half of all applications
film from California in California
entrepreneurs and there are people who
really really care about the environment
I happen to be one of them Leslie's
another one of them we are we have the
crazy people here I think closely and
some of you probably do as all of you do
is maybe the reason you're here you know
that the environmental mandate is a is a
big one and the reason I put this slide
up is not to talk about the Pacific Gyre
which some of you may have heard of
which is an area the size of Texas which
is who has a vast amount of plastic in
it which is killing sea life and
birdlife from the rest of it and it's
not to talk about peak oil and it's not
to talk about the fact that consumption
is skyrocketing in parts of the world
where there wasn't great consumption
like China and India and it's not to
talk about the fact that we have farty
month or more waste than we can deal
with is to talk about the fact that
there is a big macro impact here in
terms of funding companies because there
is plenty of money out there from
institutions that care venture
capitalists in spite of what they say
typically do not care venture capitalist
care about the bottom line and that's
really what they're looking for many of
them will personally care but they
cannot invest their limited partners
money in something which doesn't look
like a good economic investment so the
environmental mandate therefore talks to
foundations and it talks to grant giving
organizations of all kinds including the
federal government
the federal government is the source of
most early stage research the federal
government every year issues something
like 30 billion dollars for early stage
research not in our space unfortunately
into cell research and the like and that
money is appropriated and is spent in
universities and the like so about 30
billion dollars worth of money every in
a very very early very very super risky
stuff that it takes to get a a new drug
started and then that research gets
picked up by by private companies it's
much less in our space it's quite quite
a difficult number to calculate but it
is it is a small number of billions of
dollars and most of the money comes from
the federal government it goes through
the National Labs and it's it's used for
very early stage research plenty of it
also go to universities so many of you
are in the right place to receive that
kind of early-stage money now that macro
issue here is just showing you how costs
have been coming down this is mainly
because of the Chinese you will see that
in some parts of the world we've hit the
stage where we have grid parity
particularly here in California and
other places where the Sun shines a lot
it nowadays actually pays you to put PV
solar photovoltaic on your rooftop at
the risk of you answering the question
you please answer the question again
does anyone have a feeling for why it
already pays apart from the sunshine in
fact the cost of these things have come
down the cost of the the solar panels
have come down so much in order filling
as to why it works to have solar panels
on your roof and why that that it's a
competitive vs vs fossil fuel derived
electricity delivered to your home over
the grid you thought Obama
I think it's partly related to the fact
that peak demand correlates with peak
supply very good excellent excellent
okay so that's part of it these peaker
plants are very expensive to run if you
need to run them and generation is very
expensive on a big scale because you
have to handle the entire spectrum you
have to have enough capacity to deliver
at the peak even when it's not all being
used which is which is one very good
point yes because you're right they're
the most in transmission right very good
so it's right there and there's another
important reason which is um China there
are there are forget with the terminals
they're helping from their own companies
to drive down the price of solar cells I
forget what the gym is sub so that so
they are but through through
manufacturing efficiencies well then oh
I believe they what they do is uh ah
forget look where it is they they they
like pay their own Chinese companies
like extra to build these types of solar
cells which ends up costing the Chinese
manufacturers subsidies subsidies think
government subsidies make a big
difference and we can take advantage of
that yes enough of the subsidies aren't
into in so much in the manufacture but
in the construction of the of the plants
and so forth yes so government subsidies
can make a big difference that's right
and yes these days to would be financing
I have a solar style that I paid cash to
put on on the roof but nowadays you hear
all these ads you'll put it on your roof
for free it's basically I mean they're
gonna break it off of your
utility bill it supposedly the consumer
comes out ahead compared to a normal
utility bill the company gets to install
the system right through it wind put
right so so the big deal the big deal
with photovoltaic is the fact there's a
lot of upfront costs but most of these
things cost a lot of money to build them
in the first place and then they're free
for a for a long time and we don't know
how long that's going to be and one of
the big deals is what happens if you
sell your house we know six months after
you've spent a lot of money on it and
that lets a calculation you might have
made you might have said well will it
increase the value of my house
sufficiently to cover the costs or will
I ever move and you know those things
but now there are solar leases which are
available and the solar lease in some
instances will take all the upfront risk
away from you and the costs of the least
per month is is less than your original
electricity bill was so absolutely yes
part of a partial payment of free trade
right very good and it drives us on to
an important topic when we come to
talking about how we finance these
things which is the risk factor because
it's all ultimately about risk all of
this is about risk and one of the big
issues and one of the reasons why we're
on the slow part of the exponential
curve is because there's risk involved
technologies are risky at the early
stage scaling them is risky and they
become much less risky when you cross
the chasm and when you've gotten two
main streets and things are starting to
grow rapidly yes so photovoltaic is one
of those technologies which has really
made huge strides anyone here had a van
of handy cuts while what's his name ray
ray Kassar having I don't have breakouts
wild whose inventor of the codes for
keyboard and he's a futurist he
predicted the downfall of the Soviet
Union and he predicted the date more or
less that a computer would be the human
at chess and all he does is kind of
futuristic to the stuff
and one of the things he says is that
markets are exponential and people don't
get this venture capitalist he says them
because they think that everything grows
in a linear fashion he said that people
misunderstood ecommerce when ecommerce
came along when you know this kind of
drive to the web first occurred the
venture capitalist respecting to see
this what really happened was this and
eventually those lines cross and you
getting them in a very good spot because
the markets growing very fast but back
in the early 2000s a venture capitalists
were pulling out of e-commerce and web
solutions because they were they were
discombobulated by this gap between the
exponential and the living lavinia they
thought this was going to happen and
they won't get in the return so they
pulled out of that space well of course
the ones that carried on did very very
well thank you very much reycarts well
says because it's an exponential process
16 years from now 16 years from now the
entire world will be powered by
photovoltaic cells for desserts now why
does he say 16 years while I explain it
took about 50 years more or less from
the very first insulation of a local
power grid in 1882 in lower Manhattan by
Thomas Edison to the date that we had a
national grid and wide diploma about 50
years took about 50 years from the first
oil powered ships in world war one to
get the stage where we had widespread
deployment of oil power and ships it
takes about 50 years for these big
infrastructure changes to take place
Curt swells calculation looking at the
exponential curve and looking at how
long since the solar cell was originally
developed is it's about we're about 16
years away from that 50-year 45 to 50
year timeframe so we'll see what happens
but these are all macro issues they're
all driving out risk they're all helping
us to get to the stage where that where
the environment which we operate in is
is one where an early stage entrepreneur
can really make a
so the investment environment we've
talked about I'm going to yes yes this
in terms of like you're talking about
like 16 years right so now nowadays in
the venture capital investor you have
this mentality of like putting money
quickly and get it out in like four
years so that that mentality of patient
capital that you require for cleantech
and stuff like that how are you going to
sort of like bring that interesting
because of IT becoming so profitable in
such a short period of time most of the
venture capital one clean tech savvy
like that chillin in three or four years
that weren't their money back four or
five times every chance so how do you
change the mentality right well it is
the 64 trillion dollar question how do
you get VCS to make their return and
unfortunately the answer for most clean
tech entrepreneurs is that venture
capitalists are not going to invest in
capital intensive long term slow growth
projects and they shouldn't they
shouldn't it's not what VCS are there to
do VCS are there to put relatively small
amounts of money into projects that
could get a 10x return in a short space
of time and the VCS who have started
projects I mean there's a very
well-known venture capital firm here who
spent something like half a billion
dollars on nuclear fusion you may even
know who the phone was but a big deal
and actually don't know where their
money is right now but I suspect that
that's that's not the kind of investment
that venture capitalists will typically
want to make and they will find it very
hard to make those kind of investments
successfully so but there are other
places where money sensibly will come
from and I'm going to cover those for
those places in this part of the
presentation okay
15 oh my goodness okay well I'm going to
kind of power through this and then I'm
going to serve handle some of your
questions thank you listening right okay
so let's just have a little look at some
of the types of cleantech funding that
we typically break this into three
different areas three different stages
of funding we talk about the conception
stage that very very early part we talk
about the seed stage and we talk about
the growth stage and obviously this
slide covers the first two so the
earliest stages and this is where the
cleantech openness is mostly involved
and kind of help that we want to give to
these companies all right so conception
stage any of you who become
entrepreneurs in the near future will
recognize this you don't already very
very soon and you will know that there
are typically a handful of ways of
finding money because at the very early
stage of a company the risk is high and
therefore the discounts you have to give
a potential investor is very high as
well and you are very limited in the
kinds of sources of investment you can
receive so the first of them is
obviously self-funding most
entrepreneurs find the money from
themselves or they give it they put in
sweat equity their own time unpaid time
to get something off the ground and of
course friends family and fools i'm sure
some of you have wealthy enough friends
or family or even some fools that
surround you fools that will will
foolishly take the risk of a very very
high-risk investment that haven't been
said my neighbor just bought himself a
two-million-dollar house not next to me
based on it a friends family and fools
investment he made enough in a friend of
his he thought the guy had was onto
something and invested in him and did
very well out of it and it is the major
source of very early stage capital
incubation now I mentioned early on that
a lot of money comes out of the federal
government and states and foundations
and goes to universities
and companies so companies themselves
can be a source of capital you can get a
job in other words in a company that's
researching a certain space and they
might support you in some way shape or
form Google is very well known to do
this sort of thing where they they will
support their employees to to engage in
something they think that matters you're
more likely interestingly enough to get
that kind of support when you're in a
kind of clean tech space then you are in
a more traditional entrepreneurial space
that there are added opportunities which
to do with the environmental mandate
that mean that you are the tips it's a
good place to be at a very early stage
people care one of the one of the
bizarre things we notice in the clean
tech companies help incredibly
passionate the entrepreneurs are in some
cases it means that they spend too long
on what is an idea will never take off
sometimes that's the downside Tom cosmic
we met a minute ago professor here and
gave me a little book called the dip
little while ago and it's a very single
book it basically says it's called a
little book on when to want to stick and
when to give up or something like that
and it's it's all about when it makes
sense in life to move on and when not if
you've got a copy of the dick I think
it's written by a Seth Godin is the
author of many books on marketing and so
the stick to it this is both an
attribute and a downside of being an
entrepreneur and but universities and
companies are very good places to be
when you're an early-stage entrepreneur
and the risk is high and you're looking
for some way of getting something off
the ground when you move on to the seed
stage when you have something when you
have the beginnings of a prototype or a
real prototype your opportunities start
to expand so there are angel investors
there are competitions and accelerators
like the clean tech open and business
plan competitions by the way the clean
tech company is not a business plan
competition we do not have anybody write
business plans in the clean tech open we
ask them to get out of the building some
of you may have had a Steve Blank who's
a professor of entrepreneurship at
Stanford and at Berkeley and the blankie
and approach to life is get out of the
building and find real people who really
might buy your thing and ask them will
you buy this thing will you buy it and
if you would bite what do you buy it for
the kind of
any that would make me a prophet and if
you wouldn't buy it why wouldn't you buy
it and we go through a process called
product market fit which is either
changing the product or the market until
you find a real way of getting this
thing launched so an accelerator can be
a very good process to go through to do
that but business plan competitions and
business competitions including the
business competition that we run at the
cleantech open which is just part of our
mix has money at the end of the rainbow
there is a in our case the grand prize
is a quarter million dollars worth of
seed investment and services the kind of
services you need to get a company off
the ground so that there's another
source of potential capital government
grants we've talked about them
universities and National Labs the
environmental mandates were important
there and the new one which of course is
coming along there's a bit of a watch
this space is crowdsourcing we haven't
seen a lot of success in crowdsourcing
this way in the clean tech space partly
because the total cost tends to be
higher and so crowdsourcing hasn't
hasn't yet come into its own but we are
looking at various things by this time
next year Leslie would have cracked that
nut so we'll find out post on by the
author's permission on crowdsourcing but
I went to a meeting last week I'll go
stick that under course protection
excellent thanks ok good um the growth
stage so this is something which you
know doesn't sound like a lot of you are
hitting this stage but it's important to
know what this looks like when you get
to the stage where you have a product
ideally you have your first customer you
found somebody who is starting to use
this thing and who likes it and will say
nice things about you and it and when
you get to the growth stage that your
opportunities open up significantly
doesn't necessarily mean funnily enough
that you have a product which is in the
market but it's ideal if you do because
the risk comes further out of it venture
capitalist in particular do not like to
take risk they want to have things
de-risked it's a wonderful vc term as
much as possible there are grants
available the advanced
Research Projects Agency for energy
arpa-e is a source of funding for
companies that are so well between the
seed stage in the growth stage and in
their particular case they will only
invest in technologies which couldn't
receive traditional funding so it's a
they're looking for disruptive exciting
things and they will only invest them in
the energy and related spaces Department
energy more broadly talking to the fence
there are lots of different areas of
government funding which tend to open up
to you loan guarantees we already talked
about cilindros is a company installing
a great big solar utility down in
Southern California right now and tax
credits many of you may have energy star
devices in your home on your
refrigerator mate it may have the Energy
Star label that's not direct money that
comes to you it's money that goes to the
purchaser but obviously it's a subsidy
so therefore it helps people to buy your
product utility rebates again are an
indirect source the utilities will will
rebate a certain amount of money if you
can find a way of making your air
conditioner more efficient for example
they will they will pay a set amount of
money why well for the reason that you
explained earlier on that the peak
generation is expensive so if they can
reduce the peaks then it's worthwhile
they're spending actually billions of
dollars in providing rebates to people
to to do that venture will obviously we
talked about this we are seeing quite a
lot of Chinese investment in this
basement and there are companies who are
both moving to China and receiving
investment from China in the US the
Chinese for reasons explained have a
more controlled environment in which to
make venture investments and therefore
the risk for them is reduced debt if you
are building something that has physical
collateral and debt is a good source
there are lots of good banks in this but
I said I can Valley Bank bridge bank and
the like are able to take a some kind of
collateral against their loan so so debt
is is a good source if you have
something physical that you can use to
secure it project finance requires a
project so
not for most of you larger angel groups
strategics now I'm going to talk about
strategic for seconds it's an answer to
your question really which is venture
capital firms really don't want to
invest in heavy science you've got a new
form of material or a coating or
something similar VC firms typically
will not invest in those they like
business models they're like low capital
intensity and they're not into the
patient capital business but strategic
investors and that means the likes of
Chevron and Dow Chemical which are the
two big biggest firms that we work
within this space have technology Scouts
and they're out looking for new ideas
and they're looking for early-stage
companies that have them the utilities
interestingly in California don't have
an R&D department they bring in from
early-stage companies all of these kinds
of things so strategic investors are
much more likely to take something which
is heavy metal which has a has a
long-term impact in a biofuel some new
groundbreaking form of photovoltaics
element like they are the kinds of
places for the patient capital for the
for the big plays for the big disruptive
expensive and why not they have a
distribution they have the marketing
expertise and so forth alrighty am a new
thing coming along the direct public
offering the direct public offering now
an IPO is it requires you to engage an
investment bank and most of us will not
have our own IPO in our lifetimes are
the kinds of things that companies that
grow really big get more often than not
these companies get acquired actually
nowadays particularly by strategic
investors because most of them are
looking for acquisitions in the in the
long-term a direct public offering is it
is a new thing rather a new thing where
whereby companies can offer shares to
their employees and to their friends and
pretty much anybody for a relatively
small sum about a hundred thousand
dollars so direct public offerings dpos
you will see more about those as time
goes on and the best of all is revenue
sell your thing it costs nothing in
terms of equity having real customers is
the lowest risk and highest reward way
of funding a company so those are the
areas I've given you kind of the
landscape there's obviously
more to be done in explaining why all
this works and how it all works but
through an introductory lecture on is I
hope this helps you understand that the
field the micro field the macro field in
the stages of getting a clean tech
company invested and you know the
process that we engage in I think I'm
going to finish probably here and just
say the following and this I think
answers many of the questions that you
throw at me this is andy harden this
smiling face on the picture here he is
professor of entrepreneurship and he
also runs the energy efficiency Center
at UC Davis a good guy he spoken to many
of our events I'm sure he spoken at
Stanford he's he's a terrific fellow who
understands the space very well what he
says is this he says ideas don't matter
an amazing thing to say to an
engineering class good ideas languish
all the time what matters execution it's
everything especially enough with
breakthrough technologies what's he
saying well what he's saying is that a
terrific team with a mediocre idea is
far more likely to get funded because
venture capitalists love great teams
than a phenomenal idea with a mediocre
team it's just one of those things now
that switches a bit when you're talking
about strategic investors strategics
will invest in a disruptive exciting
even expensive even slow growing product
but for the most part when you're
talking about venture capital it is not
so much about the idea as the company
and the team that will put it together
why because great teams will figure out
the challenges if the if the idea isn't
good enough where is a great idea with
the poor team is very unlikely to make
it in the market oh so these early stage
companies I'm sorry to say tend to fail
okay so I'm gonna stop there and I'm
going to turn to your questions because
i'm down to about to an hour second
problemo all right all right well then
you know let's have a look so um
Philippe out of their chair ask the
question line and I did try an answer as
many of the questions as we went along
as I could so anyone want to ask any
questions otherwise I'm going to turn to
soon stop giving you some where and
other questions here it is ok any
questions you want to throw at me I just
pick up one or two of these how can an
interested citizen who's not an engineer
agree not Roberto make a difference what
role can lawyers play who's the lawyer
here no lawyer you're the liar the G
haces question I wouldn't know ok ok
lawyers this isn't this I'll answer this
one very specifically for you proterra
the company i mentioned is has on his
team on their team the chairman of the
clean take up in board funnily enough
who is a lawyer wilson sonsini attorney
and he has a his whole role is to engage
with bus companies because this is the
bus company with with bus fleet
operators around the country get them to
place a contingent order then to run to
Washington DC and make sure the grant
money can go out so the advocates
there's a lot of advocacy in the in the
legal space available that's one example
but there are plenty more lawyers in the
US always have a business role to play
so there we go I won't dwell on it um
okay alright so what makes a really
successful clean tech company um what
our venture capitalist and so forth
looking for all I've mentioned they're
looking for market team technology but
let's start right at the top of this
kind of pile here and say that a clearly
defined market with a compelling need is
the biggest thing and this is not to do
with clean tech so there with any kind
of cloudy search company a clearly
defined market with a compelling need is
ultimately what it really comes down to
followed by a team and in third place
the technology that solves the problem
unfortunately most of us start with the
technology we start with this kind of
crazy wonderful idea and we then look
for the market and we then build the
team around it it's fine as long as you
have all three of those things so yes
seeing that fitted fair all right
well I am that's it's a kind it's a kind
of difficult one to answer but I will
tell you one that hasn't yet made it and
I'm and I'm hoping will I think it's a
very good one company called Z dynamics
has a product which is based on a
mineral called zeolite and zeolite is
abundantly available but they've
discovered a process for a grinding
zeolite up and be mixing it in with
rubber that will extend the life of your
tires on your car by a dramatic factor
four or five times and zeolite can be
using toothpaste to make your teeth
whiter and it can solve the challenges
of the earth I think it's a partly a
cure for cancer it's an extraordinary
thing so I'm you know when the judges Z
dynamics is back in the game again this
year so we have that could we had the
cleantech open often has companies to go
through the process multiple times Z
dynamics came in for the second or third
time this year they when they finish
judging a few years back one of the
judges said if I had a million dollars
and I could risk it I'd put my money on
them because what they're doing is is so
out there okay well I think I've run at
a time if there's anything you else you
want to ask me I will be here for a few
minutes afterwards if you want to ask
many questions I'll stick around but
thank you all for your attention and I
was useful
you